let me pull this story from the
Independent Biden slams Republican
attempts to ban gender affirming Health
Care in interview with transgender
Tick-Tock star maybe you guys saw this
one the president's conversation comes
the Republicans continue to pass
numerous anti-transgender pieces of
legislation Biden met with Dylan
Mulvaney my personal opinion is that
Dylan Mulvaney is intentionally trying
to insult and mock trans people and
women and that is is not uh
behaving seriously but uh control that's
what you think I think delmoven is
absolutely trolling absolutely I think
that I think that he has
um like Arrested Development from his
like his childhood years and that that's
how he pictures women and yeah he's
going
I got one point for you wearing high
heels in the woods
those
uh consumerist objects really
um yeah if it's what you think uh if
it's Arrested Development and sort of a
child's view of I think all of it is
arrested
I think I I feel like that's naive Dylan
has that viral video saying these are my
hiking heels that is a phrase that
doesn't exist Barbie pouch what's the
other thing there's a bunch of insulting
words that Dylan uses to mock women in
their in their in their Tick Tock videos
but that's how a lot of these these
transgender people are anyway like
they're big is that mutually exclusive
with being genuinely dysphoric so if you
take a look at I'll use two examples
that I've used before and that's Contra
points and Blair white they are both
prominent political trans people and
they do not behave that way they behave
like they and and neither does Contra
they are both uh you can disagree with
either of their politics and they both
create well-made YouTube videos
discussing their points because just
just because someone is trans does that
mean they're going to be inherently one
way or the other and and Blair brings up
the uh uh I don't think Blair has
Arrested Development either I mean like
that's why I'm arguing when when Dylan
Mulvaney makes a video wearing heels in
the woods going
that's that's a come on you think that's
not trolling like if someone put on
blackface and started running around
screaming Fried Chicken we'd be like
that dude is trying to insult black
people not that they have Arrested
Development they think they're black I
think that he's exploiting it and using
it to his Advantage but I think he is
definitely mentally ill and and
like because he was like a gay guy in
theater right and he was on Broadway or
something like that I got like a little
crazy and I was bored and I watched a
lot of his videos like over and over
again uh a couple days ago but like I
really think they have that look that
like SSRI mentally ill look and why go
by Dylan after a transition so that's a
girl name no no look don't can be this
is this is the game right here
if you look
when you look at Dylan Mulvaney what do
I see I see someone who has created a
caricature which creates a weapon for
people to attack trans people because
I'll mention it again Blair white and
Contra points left and right extremely
prominent and normal behaviors granted
you can disagree with the idea of being
trans or doing dysphoria and say it's in
the DSM-5 therefore you know it's
considered a mental disorder according
to DSM-5 what about him like really
going through the process getting laser
hair removal on his face and actually
doing the physical steps like if it I
would think that he would be more of a
troll if he didn't commit to it
physically if that's a troll that's
psychotic obviously he's definitely
psychotic and if it's a mocking
caricature like you say like blackface I
think the reason that it would be more
effective and Powerful as a way to mock
women
um compared to Black Faces that like
your gender is a lot more uh crucial to
who you are like who you are as a person
than your race I think your race is just
uh surface level thing about you but
your gender is way more uh core to who
you are and how you relate to people but
more egregious than that is that the
White House is entertaining it like it's
something serious to be talked about
like there are so many other things
going on but sure sure here's an easy
question though so like regardless of
who's right on whether you know Blair
said Dylan is not trolling and I okay
but I look at this why didn't the White
House invite Contra points Contra points
has million million plus subscribers
getting millions of views on these these
hour-long essays that are extremely
prominent on the left with that that
that are calm well and well put together
videos again you can disagree with it
but for more left or right I know okay
because I I know players right so like
that's why I bring up these two specific
examples because they're very prominent
uh you know a contrary has like a
million and a half subscribers gets
millions of views Joe Biden could have
been like here's a person I can bring
here to talk about these issues that is
calm rational and and politically
prominent Dylan Mulvaney is not
politically prominent and and if you're
trying to advocate for Trans rights the
last person any anyone would bring is
going to be Dylan Mulvaney here's the
thing though like their comps team like
everybody knows that when you're working
in political comms you insert yourself
into the news cycle and Dylan has been
in the news cycle where Contra has like
I've never heard of it but I've
definitely heard of it might be Dylan
before before the White House it might
be conscious internet footprint if you
will that also
substantially larger controversial but
it's the internet footprint that they
don't want because that's something that
you have to answer for like timing and
it's time for conscious old old videos
like those were kind of Politically
Incorrect
I think there's something to answer for
there you try to insert yourself into
the news cycle you hit on something
that's big he just had a couple videos
that went viral and they're trying to
capitalize on it that's that's right
shallow is easier but but hey guys the
memes are awesome the memes are
incredible when it comes to this entire
topic especially when they had another
influence over take over the
communications at the White House and
they were just tick-tocking the whole
time around the nails yeah today just
moments ago I also tweeted uh the
American people looking all disheveled
uh saying please I can't afford food or
gas and then Danny DeVito coming off and
saying best I could do is this
transgender here that we're going to be
talking about and and as you mentioned
Tim you're absolutely right this is not
an issue that of course brings America
together this is an issue that divides
America the administration right now has
many problems our society has many
problems that we're facing right now and
this is this is what we're talking about
this is what they're pushing forward as
their agenda to me this is the perfect
way to distract people to divide and
conquer them to have no fighting amongst
themselves as Society literally crumbles
all around so let's Advance conversation
to the next point in the article Joe
Biden coming out and saying States
should not be allowed to ban sex changes
for children and to me I'm wondering why
what it what is what do the Democrat
Bill Maher made this point when they
were talking about it was I think it was
in 2020 I was in 2018 Democrats were
advocating for transgender rights and
prisons and Bill Maher said I get it we
want to protect civil rights but this is
like 300 people why are they putting it
front and center now you could argue of
course hey man marginalized the most
marginalized voices probably need the
most help because no one pays attention
to them for exactly what Bill Maher is
saying no one's paying attention to this
small group of people therefore someone
needs to
but when Joe Biden comes out choosing an
extremely extremely divisive issue and
one that is extremely unpopular I have
to wonder
why who whose vote he's trying to secure
by coming out and saying children should
get sex changes
I don't know whose vote he's trying to
secure but I will say that you know this
all it all goes back to the um
the Civil Right the Civil Rights era
legislation and so no matter what these
like small minorities do as long as they
couch it in civil rights language
they're never going to get beat no
matter what the vote says because it's
like enshrined and quote the
Constitution so they can say whatever
they want like it the voting population
won't matter it may like slow it or or
you know if if we object to it
temporarily but it's enshrined in law
that like if you count anything in you
know civil rights terminology that it's
going to stay like that so I mean I
guess he's just trying to be on quote
the eventual right side of History
because that's what's going to happen
given what we did in this in what 64. I
think one thing the Democrats do and all
politicians is try is compartmentalize
information and they don't know how to
do it right now and that's the problem
the example being Hillary Clinton when
she was is 2015 I think she went to
where was it Arkansas or Alabama the hot
sauce no she went on Southern drawl Oh
yeah talk a little like this and it's
like Hillary you were in New York for
the longest this time on TV we know you
don't talk like that but back in the old
days you could get away with that
imagine what would have must have been
like campaigning before radio you'd show
up to Boston and you'd put on a Boston
accent people like hey sounds just like
me and then you go to New York and you
say both instead of both and all of a
sudden people think you sound like them
and you go down to South and you talk
like this and everyone's like but no one
could know how you really talk because
you can't write down you know if someone
was at an accent or something right
that's true then we get radio then we
get TV then we get the internet even
with TV local news is not going to play
the video of Hillary Clinton in you know
New York's not going to play the Alabama
footage they're going to play the New
York footage now we have the internet
also there's a viral video of Hillary
Clinton putting on a fake accent all of
a sudden there's a even AOC I'm just
going to say yes people said that she
was imitating that Meme where that
little kid is like listen Linda listen I
think that they were I think she was
doing that or what she just tried it's
not it's not the accent it's not that
one there was another event she went to
a couple it was like a year or two ago
where she had a really heavy Latina
accent even though everyone's like we've
you went to where did you go to school
like Boston University or something like
you don't talk like that that's crazy my
favorite thing about that whole clip was
like she's like oh classy classy like
that's what they say and she's sitting
there like spread eagle like in the
middle on the stage like and she's like
he's classy and her legs are like
spread open out on the floor for
everyone I'm like oh you're so good
she's so gross I think when they when
Joe Biden has someone like Dylan
Mulvaney at the White House what they're
probably looking at is
this is a person who has all of these
gen Z followers so whatever we say here
doesn't apply outside this bubble right
like they still live in this world where
they think meeting with this influential
person won't Ripple outwards go back 50
years meet with a civil rights leader
and do an interview talking about how
you're gonna defend defend their work
you're hoping that civil rights leader
will go out to all of their all of their
followers and say Here's what they told
me but is someone who's not a fan of
that person gonna listen to what they
have to say no
what Biden is hoping for is
a hundred people here what I've just
said today and vote for me and maybe
only 10 people hear it outside of this
bubble and get mad at me for it
compartmentalizing the information
thinking you can say whatever you want
because it won't reach the outer the
larger public so I think there's
are interested in this trans agenda
thing right you have big Pharma that's
going to make tons of money on it but
not just with the drugs themselves but
with like even if you're confusing
children years and years of therapy like
that all costs money right so big Pharma
has an interest in propping up this
stuff right the left does because they
think it's like the sympathy we're the
good guys vote and then you also have
like the creeps that took advantage of
like the regular LGBT stuff and say hey
if we couch it in these same terms then
you know we can have pedophilia whatever
so you have all these interests that
while are not the same because you know
how everybody on the right like the left
says oh you're talking about they like
who's the they where's the big
conspiracy theories it's not like that
they're all in like there's one guy like
pulling the strings and of course there
might be a couple that are really
influential but they all have competing
interests like big Pharma definitely has
an interest in pushing this
um along with you know well every
company that makes money yeah they get
patients that are hooked for the rest of
their lives you get them in early
especially the young children children
you're going to have someone that's
going to be buying your product every
single month because they need to in
order to live and then remember they use
this and they dump money into his
campaign remember the report that said
it was something like pharmaceutical or
Wall Street said that cures are probably
Bad Business yep it was a Goldman Sachs
assessment saying maybe we shouldn't
cure people because that will hurt our
profit motive this is the kind of
satanic megalom how do you say that word
megalomaniacal thinking of of these
lunatics who are essentially truly
calling the shots have the big big
corporate lobbyist and when you look at
Dylan mulvini like how do you explain
him again testing tampons but then the
next day trying to normalize women
having bulges this is just that's why
I'm saying this is a control it's a
desperate need for clout that's what it
is I just looked at Dylan Mulvaney's
Instagram story and saw a picture
captioned peeing at the White House
I'm telling you this person like that's
just somebody who is desperate for cloud
I wouldn't be surprised if in a year
Dylan Mulvaney comes out and says you
are all so dumb because all this is is
mocking women and mocking trans people
now we have to ask ourselves why is this
happening I mean according according to
a topographer 80 pull uh 80 of Americans
don't support gender treatment for
children so why are they doing this is
it someone at the White House saying hey
Dylan movini's getting all these views
maybe if you get them to the White House
we'll we'll get him to support our cause
and get and tell everyone to vote for us
but people don't understand maybe people
are just watching because it's a car
crash all right I got a conspiracy
theory for you China wants Trump to win
Saudi Arabia wants Trump to win
Tick-Tock is controlled by the CCP and
they are advancing ideologies that are
sabotaging the Democrats because
when Trump is president now a lot of
people might think red top of their head
no Trump was hard on China that was bad
for China was it Donald Trump goes
America first brings manufacturing back
to the United States in the short term
bad for China in the long term Donald
Trump doesn't want to go to war doesn't
care about the Belton Road initiative
doesn't care about Africa and South
America Donald Trump cares about America
America First in the long run that's
actually really good for China you can
make the argument so Tick Tock comes out
promoting these ideologies the Democrats
Embrace and then Democrats lose Donald
Trump gets in Donald Trump says I don't
understand why we're in NATO I don't
understand why we're in Syria I don't
understand why we're in Afghanistan
China moves in Afghanistan China moves
into other parts of the Middle East
Russia expands their gas Monopoly all
things that may be bad hypothetically
for other parts of the world or who
knows
but most most of the people who support
Trump are like why do we care about
these other these things why do we care
about you know what other countries are
doing why why do we care about
intervening in Foreign Wars in Ukraine
so China may be looking at the bigger
picture like hey if Trump is President
America gets out of our way well you
know Biden's giving you know China
Afghanistan on a silver platter
especially when the corporations have
come in when you look at the conflict in
Ukraine you do see China benefiting from
it because it's the United States versus
Russia NATO versus Russia and they're
kind of in the middle watching two
enemies kind of fight each other and
Destroy themselves this is an
opportunity for China to potentially
even take Taiwan so I would just counter
that with those two points when it comes
to theorizing about this Theory thanks
for checking out this segment from the
timcast IRL podcast but if you want to
check out the full show live tune in
Monday through Friday at 8 pm and if you
want more special access content head
over to timcast.com and become a member
your member membership helps sustain
this company keep our journalists
employed makes this show happen and you
will get access to exclusive members
only segments of the timcast IRL podcast
and there's a massive library to check
out so again go to timcast.com or tune
in Monday through Friday at 8pm and
we'll see you all there